let me quickly tell you who I am my name
is wen garden I'm from Belgium I think
most of you know that well probably
because of beer and chocolate and other
tasty yummy things and all looking
buildings maybe I started the company
about 18 years ago now called cube
solutions we do mostly PHP development
we also do quite a bit of infrastructure
which explains why I'm doing a talk
about networking of course and we just
also started a training service called
tech path and I've been doing open
source for the last 20 or so years and I
wrote things like PHP compatibility
which is a tool you might want to check
out if you need to migrate your code to
peach b7 dot X and I've been doing talks
like these for quite a while ok let's
see who you are who here is a developer
yeah most people any system engineers
anyone doing Network yeah anyone network
engineer oh you know one ok that's good
but who knows how the internet works
completely a few hands and then they
went down again ok so yeah obviously
we're we're web developers we might be
you know DevOps maybe or scissors we're
not network engineers in general except
the few people here but we know enough
to build stuff obviously we know enough
to maintain existing configurations
existing servers and so on but let's
imagine the customer calls your boss and
says order the support desk and says the
website is slow please fix it well
that's all good and well and they might
call you and say the website is slow fix
it please and you go on the website and
you have no problem because maybe the
problem is not your code maybe the
problem is not database related maybe
the problem is network related so what
do you do how are you gonna fix it as a
developer and so that involves knowing
things like DNS yes TCP BGP whatever
else you know a lot of different
terminology that most developers have
never encountered or yeah they know sort
of what it means but don't know the
basics of it so that's what this session
is kind of about getting you getting
those of you who don't know a lot about
networking up to speed to a little bit
more of the basic understanding of how a
network works and how the bigger
Internet the bigger network called the
internet works okay so networking
there's a model that describes different
layers that we have on the network and
basically it starts with layer 1 which
is a physical network which is basically
your wires your network cards your
wireless interface and so on and we have
layer 2 on top of that which is the
datalink layer which is the data
protocol
usually it's Ethernet we use Ethernet
the most there's a few others but we're
not going to discuss that
then there's layer 3 the network layer
which we all know I think which is about
IP addressing and yeah that's basically
what we do all the time and then there's
the transport layer on top of it which
is TCP which we all use every day
UDP things with ports everything lives
in that layer then it gets a bit blurry
because the session layers well there's
TLS and there there's l2tp Sox and a few
other things but some people say that
that lives in layer 6 and other people
say now that belongs to layer 5 and it
gets even more blurry when we go to
layer 6 which is about serialization and
data translation and then finally we end
up with layer 7 which is where we build
our stuff which is it's about HTTP DNS
and stuff like that so we build on top
of that I can go on these are the seven
official original layers
some people describe layers up to layer
12 and it gets even blurry or so yeah
but networking basically revolves around
bits of data that are being sent over a
physical cable or Wireless and are being
translated on the other end into bits of
data and these bits of data usually
grouped together in packets and a
packets always consists of a header and
actual content
now packet can packets can contain and
usually do contain other packets so you
have a packet which has contents and
then that contents has another packet
which has header and s contents and so
on so it basically looks a bit like this
this is in Internet packets which has a
destination MAC address which I'll get
to in a minute and a source address and
a type which in our case is usually IP
the type and then it has a payload and
that payload is basically another packet
in this case an IP packets which has a
lot of headers as you can see and then
at the bottom of it it says contents of
the packets which means there's another
packet in it in this case a TCP packet
and so you can have multiple layers deep
and so on so if you send a packet from
one machine to the next then it's going
to have to get each packet out of the
previous packet and basically sort of
sort of yeah I would say unpack it yeah
and then if it needs to transmit that to
the next host it's going to take all
those bits and pieces and group them
back together in the right order and
send it along again so that's how
networking actually uses packets so if
we look at an example a typical example
is an internet packet because we use
Ethernet all the time and that contains
an ipv4 packets and that then contains a
TCP packet and so on now okay
so we have here a destination MAC
address and the source MAC address now
these are sort of the basic concepts
without those networking on Ethernet
would not work what is a MAC address a
MAC address is basically a unique
identifier for every single device on
network it's supposed to be unique
worldwide but as you can tell six bytes
is not a whole lot so theoretically
there could be conflicts in reality
there shouldn't be yet but if we keep
adding more and more devices we will run
into trouble of course at some point now
let's first talk about how
we send data across a local network so
imagine that we have a device a couple
of devices here all wired up on a local
network how do we send that well the in
the old days we used to use a device
called a hub now a hub looked a little
bit like this
you will recognize standards rj45 ports
but you'll also recognize a coax port
there which is not really in use a lot
anymore today
the problem with the hub was all devices
could be sending at the same time so you
would get one device sending a packet
and another device sending at the same
time and it would collide it would be a
collision as they called it
and then it would have to retransmitted
a hub worked on layer 1 so purely on on
the data on the physical layer not very
efficient not very fast speeds usually
limited to well 10 megabits per second
so not very efficient luckily we got in
the next phase somewhere in mid 90s we
got a better device for that and we used
a switch which whoops okay which looks a
little bit like this which we all
recognize I think and what happens here
is as I said every device on the network
has a MAC address which is supposed to
be unique it's assigned by any
manufacturer now you can override it if
for example you're setting up VMware
then you're actually creating virtual
MAC addresses you can define them
yourself you can modify them if you want
which means you can mess with things as
well now if you are located on the same
physical network like if you plug into
this switch with two devices you are on
the same physical network then the way
you communicate is by sending in
Ethernet packets with the destination
MAC address and the switch actually
knows which device has which MAC address
so which port on the switch has which
MAC address so it knows where to send
that traffic
so that's layer 2 if you want to send IP
traffic well IP as part of an IP packet
is part of an Ethernet packets
so you're still sending the same kind of
packets it's just you're adding a
package within the package and then you
require IP addresses now where do you
send them well on a local network all we
can do is send things to a MAC address
because that's easier net so we use a
thing called ARP to find out the MAC
address of the device we want to
communicate you how does that work well
this is actually what such a packets
translated in human readable form looks
like this is an ARP request basically
192 168 0 12 is requesting the MAC
address of 192 168 0 15 and so that
device is saying hey I'm looking for the
MAC address can someone tell me and then
the one with dot 15 at the end is going
to reply and say top 15 is at this MAC
address and now the two devices can
actually communicate because they know
each other's MAC address this is cached
this is stored in a so called ARP table
so that you don't have to do this lookup
for every single packet that you want to
send now what is local traffic basically
local for IP means you're on the same IP
subnet I'm sure most of you have heard
of what a subnet is but what is it
really
what is it defined so if we look at IP
version 4
which is what most servers are still
running on we'll get to IP version 6
later it uses CIDR notation classless
inter-domain routing notation not
important it looks like this we all
notice so four numbers separated by a
dots where each number is between and
including 0 and 255 so goes from 0 0 0
and so on to 255
in reality what doesn't that means is
it's 4 times 8 bits so the address could
look a little bit like this for example
192 4 32 1
in reality is sent across the wire as a
number of bits now this means if you
have four times eight bits
it means 256 but times 256 x 256 x 256
addresses or two to the power of 32 or
4.3 billion sort of that's the total
number of IP addresses that are
available to the world
we'll get to why that's a problem I mean
you can already tell if there's eight
billion of us and we have only 4.3
billion addresses that's kind of a
problem but I'll get back to that now IP
networking requires an IP address M as I
previously said a subnet mask now what
is that subnet mask all it defines
basically is okay you have an IP address
but to which range of IP addresses does
this IP belong so it kind of puts sort
of a limiter on the range to which it
belongs
it basically says yes I know this IP
address is part of the 4.3 billion but
it's also part of a limited network and
the reason to do that is that any
address that's part of the same range
can talk to each other locally without
having to go through some kind of router
without having to go through other
devices so any IP within that range can
talk to each other for example this
range 194 50 97 0 to 255 has a certain
subnet mask and any any IP addresses in
that same range are considered to be
locally on the same network so they can
talk to each other directly
now there's two notations for that well
I'm gonna go back so a subnet mask can
be defined in the first notation the 255
dot and so on or it can be defined as
slash 24 you often see that when you go
on Linux command line and you type IP
address or ifconfig or so on then you
often see a notation like that slash
24/25 and so on
the reason it is expressed that way is
basically ipv4 gives you two to the
power of 32 and then a slash 24 will
give you two to the power of 32 minus 24
so 2 to the power of 8 so it's gonna
give you 256 addresses quickly want to
mention there's three exceptions I'm
pretty sure you recognize the last one
one ninety two dot one sixty eight dot
zero dot zero that's usually the IP you
get from your local router at home from
your ISP those are ranges that do not
work on the internet the only work on
local networks that IP is not routable
anywhere in the Internet now let's look
at a quick example let's say we have
arranged one ninety four seven one zero
slash 24 that means it's arranged from
1.0 to one dot 255 it contains 256
addresses and let's imagine you want
eight addresses to install your server
zone then you could just use this range
or you could say well I only need eight
so I'm gonna make a smaller range
instead of 256 addresses and I'm going
to reserve that range specifically for
my servers and they're gonna be on this
specific switch or router and so on so
you could say I want a slash 28 now what
is a slash 28 well it's choose to the
power of 32 minus 28 so it's gonna give
you 16 addresses now you might think
wait a slash 29 will give me eight
addresses and I need eight addresses
that's perfect the problem is every
single subnet that you make the first
address is called the network address
and the highest address is called the
broadcast address and you cannot use
those on top of that each subnets
usually needs a default gateway so
you're losing three addresses so out of
16 you have 13 usable this also means
the more subnets you make the more
addresses you will lose so the 4.3
billion given how many networks there
are in the world networks subnets there
are in the world we lose a lot of those
for point
billion anyway so the subnet in this
case 1 94 7 1 0 / 28 also written in a
different way which I'm not gonna get
into right now now to be cleared the
something that doesn't have to start at
the dot 0 it can also start at dot 16 or
dot 32 or dot 48 it all it can only
start though at a multiplication of the
number of addresses so a slash 28 which
has 16 addresses can only start on dot
1.16 dot 32 and so on but you can make
combinations so if you have a big range
of 256 addresses you can make it start
at dot 0 and go to 127 with a slash 25
and then the next one can start at 128
and go to 159 and so on so any
combination makes sense you can just not
overlap of course that wouldn't work
devices that overlap on the same range
they would not be able to talk to each
other in a in a decent way just
something I want to throw in between if
you ever want to check if an IP is
inside a range we're at a PHP conference
so I have to show something of PHP right
so this is a very convenient piece of
code which basically avoids that you
have to do all sorts of parsing and
checking with dots and splitting and
then doing all sorts of weird
calculations basically what it's doing
it's using IP to long to turn an IP
address into a long and then printing
it's printing the bits 32 bits and then
running substring compared just the
check is this IP within this range in
what six lines of code very convenient
anyone ever heard this phrase I think
there's a world market for maybe five
computers someone said it in somewhere
in the 50s I think it was a someone
working for IBM or 640 K is more memory
than anyone ever need something at Bill
Gates
at some point and that's another one 4.3
billion IP addresses is more than enough
that's what they thought in the 70s when
they built ipv4 it is not enough we are
running out and we have been running out
for a while
4.3 billion doesn't cover it anymore
especially with mobile devices so ipv6
was created published in 1998 but it's
still not being deployed everywhere it's
we're slowly getting there
most major sites have it more and more
ISPs at home have it but a lot of small
sites are still behind and now an ipv4
address well you already saw that an
ipv6 address looks a little different a
little bit longer now luckily anywhere
where you see four zeros you can
actually remove that and say double
colon double colon but you can only do
that once so you cannot have four zeros
and then something else and then four
zeros and remove both of those the
problem is ipv4 and ipv6 cannot talk to
each other they live side-by-side they
can run on the same devices but they
cannot communicate with each other so
basically if you want to use ipv6 and
you want to fetch something from a
website you can only communicate with
that website if they are also running
ipv6 now to give you an idea the address
space of ipv6 is two to the power of 128
which is that many addresses we are not
going to run out anytime soon please
don't quote me on that and to give you
an idea of the deployment rates globally
22 percent of people at home have ipv6
in the US it's a little more Belgium is
number one here we cross the 50% barrier
last year which is good but still a long
way to go of course should you use it
yes should you just tell your network
engineer or yours sis ops guy enable
ipv6 no be careful on any Linux
environment
I think on Windows it's the same thing
firewall ruling rules are set per
protocol so if you have a firewall rule
set for ipv4 it's not activated for ipv6
so if you just enable ipv6 you're gonna
run into trouble because you're
basically you have no firewall rules
enabled at all
so yes you should use it but you should
look at your firewall in first
okay so we talked a lot about IP
addresses now let's see if we can send
some IP traffic on a local network so we
have a client here we have a server and
they're on the same IP range and the
client wants to make a connection and
fetch information and so on first thing
he has to do is well they're on the
local network the only way they can
exchange information is over Ethernet so
they need an Ethernet packets and in
that Ethernet packet they need a MAC
address so he's gonna send an ARP
request and say does anyone know the MAC
address for that IP and that servers
going to reply and say yep this is my
MAC address and now they can talk
because now they can exchange Ethernet
packets and within those Ethernet
packets there are IP packets and so on
now how do I pee packets find their way
when they want to go beyond that when
they want to go anywhere really how do
they know whether they're on the local
network or not well they use routing for
that each layer 3 network which so each
IP network has a routing table and you
can easily find that on Linux you just
type route on Windows you type a route
to print and then it gives you output
that looks a little like this and what
you can see here is that yeah ok so you
can see at the back there's I face
interface which is basically the network
interface that you're plugged into so we
have two of them here eth1 eth0 and you
can see here there's a difference
between this route and that route just
with a flag so the one that has no G in
there is basically one that's defined by
your network interface the one that does
have a G has a gateway address
this one all the IP addresses on this
interface are directly available on eth0
this one is available on eth0 as well
but only through a gateway that means
any packets that is being sent to this
range is actually being transmitted to
that gateway so using the MAC address of
that gateway now the top one is a
special case it has destination zero
zero zero zero which basically means
anything else in most cases this means
the Internet so anything else is being
sent to ten zero zero zero one
now where does 1000 one live oh it lives
on on the second range so it lives on a
th one so this is a way to see actually
where is my traffic going to go so if
you want to send IP traffic to a remote
device where do you send it well if that
remote device is not on your local
network then you cannot send it because
you need a MAC address of the device
and MAC addresses are not shared beyond
the local network so then you use that
routing table and you send it to the
default gateway the default gateway is
something that's provided usually
statically on a server so you just set
it up your network engineer will say
this is the default gateway or if you
have a router at home for example it's
provided by that router using DHCP and
so what happens then is if we want to
communicate from our client to our
server somewhere on the internet then
we're going to say okay I want to
communicate to the Internet which means
I have to use my default gateway which
is that router over there I'm gonna ask
for the MAC address because that router
is on my local network within the same
IP range I'm gonna get that MAC address
back and now I'm gonna send a packets in
Ethernet packets to my router not to my
server to my router and within there is
a TCP packets for one ninety four seven
one for the server the router is going
to get that
packets say oh I got an internet package
what's inside the ethernet packet oh
there's an IP packet I have to send it
to the server okay I'm gonna make a new
Ethernet new Ethernet packets for the
next router I'm going to put that IP
packet in there I'm gonna send it along
and the next router is gonna do exactly
the same thing until in the end it's
gonna end up on the server on the other
side so you can imagine if you're
sending a packet to the other side of
the world and it's crossing 20 routers
this happens every single time and then
the return packets
same thing yeah you can see the full ARP
table on any operating system with ARP
dash a and I already said route dash n
or rad print so let's have a look at TCP
packets because we use those all the
time
HTTP is sent across TCP so this is what
a TCP packet looks like the content is
here above that is a lot of headers and
there's they're all important but I want
to focus on three now which is sequence
number acknowledgement number and flag
so what happens when you try to connect
establish a TCP connection between a
client and a server the first thing that
happens is clients sends a packet and in
that packet is a flag syn the flag sin
is set and it sends a sequence number
which is generated in a certain way it's
sort of random let's imagine right now
that it's a thousand and it always
increments so it sends it and if the
server receives it the server's gonna
reply and if you wants to accept that
connection it's going to reply with the
packets with two flag set sin and ack
and the sequence number is now one
higher and there's an acknowledgement
number saying yes I agree I acknowledge
your message also with a number and then
the client is going to reply again with
a flag a key I acknowledge that you
acknowledged with the sequence number
one higher and the acknowledgement
number one higher and now we can
communicate now the client can also say
I'm sending a get request so
this is called a three-way handshake
going back and forth now let's imagine
we want to communicate between Brussels
and Montreal and let's imagine that the
minimum time for that is 45 milliseconds
that means after 45 milliseconds my sin
packet has arrived 90 milliseconds here
I send a get with request after 135
milliseconds the server's finally
received what I want to what I want the
server to execute a get request I want
to retrieve some piece of information
that takes a long time imagine we do it
between Brussels and London and it's 10
milliseconds then obviously that only
takes 30 milliseconds in total so you
can see why sometimes it's a good idea
to have more in one location for your
data so that clients from the other side
of the world can actually access it a
lot faster so that's one way of
improving speed there's another way
it's called TCP window size for anyone
running on older version of Linux and
older Linux kernel this is the reason
why you should upgrade so you have a syn
we have a syn ACK and the server can
actually mention a size of packets the
maximum amount of data that it can
receive so it can say 8 kilobytes and
then the client can say yeah I agree
I can also receive 8 kilobytes and then
the server's going to reply back and say
I can also receive 16 kilobytes if
that's fine and the client is going to
reply back with 16 kilobytes and so on
and it can go with ipv4 it can go up to
it up to 64 kilobytes but the bigger
that size the larger the packets are
going to be so if you have a lot of data
to send you're going to be able to send
it in less round trips because every
single time let's imagine the server has
to reply with 500 megabytes of data it's
going to be one packet at a time in this
case so it's gonna be 8 kilobytes 8
kilobytes 8 kilobytes 8 kilobytes if you
have 45 millisecond delay we
- it's going to take a long time so if
you can increase the packet size the
number of tie it's going to reduce the
number of times it has to go back and
forth recent Linux kernels have a higher
standard value for that there's also
something called tcp slow-start so what
that does is it allows the server to say
oh I'm sending two pack two packets back
already and I'm waiting for you to
acknowledge both and if you do that I'm
gonna send you four packets and if you
acknowledge all four I'm gonna send you
eight and so it keeps increasing keeps
multiplying by two until at some point
the client doesn't reply anymore or
doesn't reply to all of them and then
he's gonna go back and go to the
previous value so in this case it's not
a matter of sending one package one
reply one package one reply it can
actually do four or eight or sixteen or
more this is also by default on newer
Linux versions so a good reason to
upgrades to the latest versions so
there's a big difference between and
this is very important this is something
web developers can change on the server
actually there's a big difference
between establishing a new connection or
reusing an existing one so if you have a
new connection well it's obvious it's
saying syn ack ack and then at the same
time we send our get request and then
the server after one hundred and thirty
five milliseconds the server says ok now
I can start processing let's imagine
that takes a hundred milliseconds means
after two hundred and thirty five
milliseconds the server can reply let's
imagine that we have tcp slow-start
enabled and we can immediately send for
and we acknowledge with four packets and
then the server sends eight packets and
we acknowledge four with eight and let's
imagine the whole bit of data was twelve
packets so we're done still it took four
hundred and fifteen milliseconds almost
half a second for a single request and
normally you would cut the connection
here you would cut TCP connection and
that would be it but let's imagine that
you still
to retrieve CSS and JavaScript and all
those things if you cut the connection
you need to establish a new one you need
to have an you through you a handshake
however if you don't cut the connection
and you can do that in Apache and nginx
and any other web server nowadays if you
don't cut the connection
it means the client doesn't have to do
it through you a handshake it can just
say give me the data it still requires a
hundred milliseconds of processing
that's your PHP doing its work but now
the server can reply immediately with 12
packets because he knew from the
previous request 8 was not a problem
Sakana try descent 16 now but we had
only 12 packets of data so it's gonna
send 12 packets and the client will
acknowledge so we just saved almost 50%
in time so don't close your connections
obviously so there's a couple of ways to
upgrade your performance upgrade to the
latest version check your windows size
whether it's properly set would use
latency well move your servers closer to
your client well if you have if you know
for example you're building a website
and it's gonna be using the UK
don't put your servers on AWS in
California it makes no sense but the mom
European instance of AWS if you have
clients both in the UK in Japan it might
make sense a lot of sense to have two
instances one here and one in Asia
somewhere and reuse established
connections already that's an easy fix
that's going into your web server
configuration and just changing that and
restarting it so this is for standard
TCP connections it also is the same
thing for anything that has to do with
HTTP connection because you have another
three-way handshake for anything that's
SSL or TLS now again if you close the
connection at the end the next time you
do a request you will have to do a
three-way handshake for TCP and
for the ssl encryption however if you
keep the connection open you can use
something called session resumption
which means you can actually resume in
one less back-and-forth so you would
gain here 90 milliseconds per requests
and i'm guessing most of us are now
using HTTP and most of the websites i'm
hoping at least given the fact that
certificates are now free basically
there is actually a good way of making
sure that your clients are always going
on HTTPS and it's a good way to make
sure that they are always secure and
they're not leaking any information
there's a thing called HSTs HTTP strict
transfer transports security it's
basically all you have to do is send a
header on the first request and what
happens is it tells your browser it
tells the clients browser hey this
website is HTTPS only switch now and
remember it and even then if you try to
type HTTP I don't know do HTTP Google
com the browser will actually add an s
automatically it will not allow you to
go it's a to http anymore for those web
sites so it for example it prevents that
you leak session cookies over unsecured
Wi-Fi because you forgot to type the s
and it's just one header that you need
to add ok so we talked about TCP a lots
because well that's what we usually use
on HTTP but there's also another thing
called UDP officially it's called user
Datagram protocol it's also called
unreliable Datagram protocol and the
reason it's called unreliable is it
because it's because it is
connectionless it doesn't establish a
connection it doesn't do three-way
handshakes it doesn't care about that it
just sends packets so it has a very
simple packet structure it has a source
port destination port which we'll get to
in a minute it
a length a checksum it still has that
and that it has contents there's nothing
else in here
there's no Flags there's no sequence
numbers or anything like that it just
sends data this means that the packet
might not arrive we don't know because
we don't wait for acknowledgement it
also means that the second packet might
arrive before the first packet so how do
you deal with data that you get then
well that's up to you that's basically
the protocol you implement within UDP
you handle some kind of sequence number
in there or you decide that if it
doesn't arrive within five seconds you
drop it so that's the reason it's used a
lot for streaming or gaming things like
that both TCP and UDP have source port
and destination port now we all know
destination port I think that's TCP port
80 TCP port 443 or UDP port 53 for DNS
the source port however is equally
important because if you connect from a
client to a server three times
simultaneously to port 80 and the server
wants to reply well if you just sends
data back then for which request was
that data so what's going to happen is
the client is actually when requesting
when opening a TCP connection is going
to use a source port it's going to say
I'm sending this request to port 80
I want this URL and I'm sending it from
port 5,000 so if you send an answer back
please send it to port 5,000 so that I
know that it's the answer for this
specific request if you want to see the
active connections so if you want to see
which ports are being used for that you
can do netstat bash em and it will give
you a huge list don't do it on a super
busy server because you will get a
massive list that's why the dash n is
there so it doesn't do dns lookups all
right let's say we want to fetch a
website because we're all web developers
so
to fetch our website for example now TCP
of course doesn't know what Cu dot B is
it doesn't deal with letters it only
deals with IP addresses so we need an IP
address we need to look it up now we
need to open a socket which we haven't
discussed yet which we'll do in a minute
so we'll connect tonight to this IP
address on port 443 we'll send an HTTP
request we'll get our data back we'll
get images CSS JavaScript preferably
over the same connection we'll close the
connection and we'll show the web page
now some of these can happen
simultaneously but I want to talk
quickly about DNS and I want to quickly
talk quickly about opening a socket
because I'm sure most of you know how
DNS works but I want to mention in
anyway a few minor things in there so
there's two types of DNS servers there
is the authoritative server which is
basically the server that's responsible
for the domain name and then there's a
recursive server the recursive server
doesn't know anything
it always needs to ask an authoritative
server and then it keeps the answer of
that server for a while it caches it
defined by the time to live usually you
will use a recursive server provided by
your ISP so what happens is our client
wants to go to our website it's gonna do
a DNS lookup ask the recursive DNS
server for the IP for C you bb and
recursively in that server says I
haven't got a clue it even thinks Diaby
e I have no idea what that is if it
doesn't even know da ve it's gonna ask
it's gonna say ok I'm going to ask
Bobbie e where that is I'm gonna ask you
to the root DNS server now there's 13 of
them worldwide there's I mean there's 13
IP addresses for them there's a few more
servers for them of course and so
whenever you have no clue what even dot
B e means or dot code that you K means
it's gonna go to a root DNS server and
it's gonna ask can you give me the IP
for Cu dot B and there
reply nope I don't know but I can tell
you the IP for the dot de DNS server you
maybe maybe you can ask them and so okay
we go and ask them we ask did all be e
DNS server can you give me the IP for
see you they'll be and they reply nope
we don't know but I can tell you the DNS
server for see you Toby you can ask them
and so then we ask them and then finally
we get the answer so there's a lot going
on here just for one single DNS request
which explains why sometimes the DNS
request takes so little time so there's
a couple of different ones also it's
quite important there's an e record
which is what we usually have which
basically points to an IP there's a quad
a record which points to an ipv6 address
so nowadays if you're in your browser
and you have an ipv6 connection you type
google.com its first gonna look up ipv6
address and if it doesn't get one back
then it's gonna look up an ipv4 address
so another reason why it sometimes it
takes a bit longer there's a cname
record which is just an alias there's MX
records which define mails records mail
servers
there's the DNS server records and then
then there's the txt records which are
usually used for anti-spam and there's a
whole lot more I'm not going to get into
those now two useful tools there are dig
and nslookup where you can that you can
use to get like completely listings of
what is present on a DNS
now each dns each domain should have at
least two DNS servers the order is not
important it's gonna pick one randomly
and DNS is udp-based now that's kind of
a good thing because it means we don't
need to establish a three-way handshake
so that's faster but it also means we
don't know if the packet arrived so we
get no acknowledgement so the only way
to fix that is by having a timeout after
X number of seconds usually two seconds
and now we try another DNS server it can
work over TCP but it's not used a lot
anymore
most people use UDP nowadays
okay so that's a bit more about DNS and
then I said I want to talk about sockets
quickly I'm sure everyone's seen sockets
in the sense of an error on the MySQL
socket or something like that this is
basically the same thing with MySQL it's
usually a file socket if you're
connecting locally this is a network
socket basically it's a layer between
your application and a protocol so that
you don't have to write a protocol
yourself anymore so it abstracts the
syntax you can switch from UDP TCP more
easily and so on and it basically
converts the data you want to send to
packets and vice versa
that's all it does again if you want to
see what is open and that's that - and
we'll show you all open connections but
also all open socket connections also
locally so let's imagine I showed this
diagram before so we're sending
information to the Internet we know now
how we can go from our client to our
router and then our router will do
something it will forward it somehow but
what happens on the internet I mean we
all work with it every day what actually
happens how is that data being
transmitted so there's a protocol door
they're called BGP border gateway
protocol and it decides how packets are
being sent from one place to the other
and it uses a system called autonomous
systems each network on the Internet
has an autonomous system number it's
just a number from one - well it used to
be 64,000 now it's a bit higher even
because there are too many networks on
the internet and BGP will actually use
so-called announcements so each
autonomous system will basically tell
other autonomous systems hey you can
reach this IP subnet through me and they
will receive that and they will
communicate that forward further upwards
so we are announcing to those two
networks and they will continue our
announcements
to the next one to the next one to the
next one so at some point every router
on the Internet knows where every single
IP range can be found that means there's
over 200,000 IP ranges in a big table in
every single router on the internet just
to be able to find out where to send
packets to so what that means is if our
client wants to go to our server our
client is connected to a s number 1 for
example that router is going to say oh
you want to go to this specific IP oh I
know where that is I need to send you
there and then that one is going to do
the same thing and gonna send you there
and then finally that one's gonna say oh
I know where it is it's on my local
network so I'm gonna send you there and
then the reply comes back and now it's
perfectly possible that that router is
gonna say yeah I can send you to a s 5
but that that link is too expensive we
pay too much money for it so I'm gonna
send you there so the returning packet
follows a completely different path
perfectly possible and actually these
two routers can be in one network and so
you can have multiple connections with
the same network
that's fine works just fine so vgp
basically looks up based on the IP
address it looks up the autonomous
system number then picks the shortest
path if there are two shortest paths
then it's going to calculate it based on
preference meaning usually money and
then it's going to send the packet along
to the Gateway ok quickly we want to
talk about something about mobile
devices so mobile devices switch between
networks switch between towers if you
have a good mobile network it's not
really a problem if you have a poor
mobile network it can be a problem your
IP address might change you you might
have connections that drop and so on
this means that three-way handshakes
also on slower connections they're an
issue so
with people using more and more mobile
devices you want to avoid having those
three-way handshake as much as possible
the best way right now is to use HTTP 2
for a number of reasons which I'll get
to on the next slide the other way of
course is keep your connections active
as I mentioned before so make sure you
you say keep alive on on Apache and
nginx and put that timeout in like 15 or
60 seconds or whatever so that you don't
drop connections right away
another problem of course is latency
connections being slow is an issue with
mobile devices now HTTP to HTTPS what we
use everyday
there's a relatively new version it's
been around for a few years now but most
web servers are not ready for I mean
haven't been upgraded yet or have not
don't have it enabled yet originally
this was done made by Google what it
allows you to do is it allows you to
make simultaneous requests HTTP requests
over one connection and get simultaneous
responses as well so you can do five
pursue quests and to get requests
simultaneously it's not an issue it's
binary which means it's a lot more
efficient it also means that you cannot
just debug it as easily because it's all
in binary and it's not very visible it's
not easy to read and encryption is kind
of standard you can disable it but
nobody does and why would you you can
also even prioritize you can say okay do
this post request but first to this get
request because that's more important
and it supports server push which is
useful for notifications and stuff like
that so it's a good alternative in that
way for WebSocket type applications try
it out deploy it getting it running very
easy you add a module which you probably
already have you add one line of code
one line of configuration and you're
done with nginx you just add HTTP to and
then yeah you have to of course add an
SSL
certificate as well and make sure it's
set up properly but that's all you have
to do and all of a sudden you can have
multiple connection and multiple
requests over a single connection and
they are a lot faster yeah some tools
you might want to know on Linux
these just I'm gonna put the slides
online afterwards I'm joined
indefinitely so these are some of the
tools you might want to get to know if
you don't know them already so on Linux
IP address is one of them shows you a
whole lot of information I ifconfig
shows you pretty much the same thing a
little bit less details but then again
it also shows you how many packets how
many bytes have crossed the interface
how many errors you have on the
interface route - and shows you the
routing table netstat is really useful
for debugging not just what active
connections you have but also if you do
- P - sorry - L - P it shows you which
process is listening on which port which
can also help sometimes to see what is
going on why am I getting errors why is
it saying that the port is already in
use and so on TCP dump is allows you to
inspect packets and there's a very nice
tool called Wireshark which allows you
to actually look at every Ethernet
packets see what is inside that packets
and then you see an IP packet and TCP
packets and even it can even decode HTTP
packets and tell you okay I got this get
request in this response and so on so it
really helps to see what's going on in
the network okay I want to illustrate
why why I'm doing this talk is basically
to help developers and realize what is
going on on the network and I want to
illustrate that with a little example
that we had with a customer of ours I'm
not going to name the customer they had
a pretty big website at the time it was
150,000 visits at the time there was a
lot and they had like a ticker on there
that ticker was actually an XML fee that
came from a website that they also owned
and it was cached for 50 minutes locally
so that they wouldn't hear it all the
time now there's a piece of code here so
we create a cache file we check if it's
older than 15 minutes then they deleted
it and then they did a file get contents
of the original feet put it back in the
cache file parsed DeFede and so on
anyone tell me what's wrong with the
code what happens if you get two
requests at the same time yeah it's
gonna go in there twice and you might
get some weird behavior very good point
yeah what else is wrong exactly you
delete it before you're gonna get the
file so you don't know yet if that gate
is gonna is gonna be successful or not
there's a lot of things that are wrong
with the code and I'll walk through all
of them but you were getting to a good
point there so the the feed was located
on that machine and then the actual web
site was located here and it was
retrieving it every 15 minutes and then
that datacenter lost power power failure
and first couple of minutes everything
was fine because the feed was still
cached and then the feed expires the
cache expires and now it's trying to
fetch that URL
everybody's going into that if structure
and well you timeout after 60 seconds
because of course that's the default in
PHP really every every visitor on that
busy website waiting 60 seconds no
refresh refresh my chrome is stuck I'm
opening a new tab I'm opening a new
browser so more load more load more load
until at some point they were using
Apache they hit the maximum connection
limit and now it's not just that single
page that sounds their entire website
that was them and so we get called in
like we look at the website and there's
400 Apache processes zero load because
they're all just sitting there waiting
for some file to be returned
so what's the issue well oops yeah this
is the fix they came up with by the way
they made a time out of five seconds and
then yeah that doesn't really fix the
problem does it matter
in the mean time hmm what is what else
is wrong here well of course we
shouldn't unlink because it's possible
that fifteen people going to the knife
structure and then if you unlink what
someone else just did a file put
contents yeah everyone else is going
back into the earth structure so that's
a bad idea
now the other thing is if we have a
timeout what this file get contents
returned any ideas it returns false so
we we would actually take false and put
that in the cache file that's not going
to parse very well of course so we want
to somehow assign that to a variable in
check for it and so on then another
thing is we're doing parse XML every
single time now you might want to do
that once and then put that content into
the cash-flow different thing of course
there's one more thing here file get
contents and file put contents in PHP
are not atomic operations so you can
actually do file put contents with two
people at the same time and that's going
to cause the file to be corrupted unless
it's a very small file but if the file
is huge and it cannot do it in one write
it's actually going to corrupt the file
plus somebody could be doing file put
contents someone else could be reading
the file it's also gonna be a corrupted
file so that's kind of an issue as well
basically here you're relying on the
user it's the user that's going to
initiate this piece of code and that's a
bad idea especially with concurrent
requests so it would be better in this
case to run that cron job every 15
minutes or so now if we're talking about
network resources in your code use
timeouts for everything whether that's
an F open or a curl request or a soap
request or whatever it is use it
don't rely on the standard timeout of 60
seconds in this case if you own that
other data source just through the
opposite direction so get the get the
feed instead of pushing it the other way
okay now if you want to ever simulate
that like how does my website behave
when we have a network issue there's a
couple of tools that might help there's
one tool that's called wonnum it's
written by an Indian company it's
basically a visual tool and you can just
say oh I want to introduce five percent
packet loss on the link and I want to
see what happens or I want to introduce
a two sec two second delay everywhere or
two second delay specifically on that
XML feed this is a very interesting tool
to use and it it makes you actually
prepare for what could possibly go wrong
on Linux there's a couple of tools for
it you can just use standard IP tables
and just say for example drop point one
and that basically means 10% of all
packets are now being dropped or you can
use TC which is traffic control and say
okay I want a delay of 50 milliseconds
with a variance of 20 milliseconds and
so then you can see how it behaves if
your network connection is erratic or
slow and so on
there's a very nice tool actually called
Comcast which is described as simulating
shitty network connections so you can
build better systems a really nice tool
that allows you to actually simulate
what could go wrong if any thing that
you connect to or that your users need
to connect to doesn't behave as expected
yeah I just want to show a few more
funny pictures of course so if it looks
like that your data room
yeah it doesn't show very well right but
that's before and after it looks a
little bit better now finally last slide
just in time
failover or disaster recovery or grades
if they work but when was the last time
you tested it of course
yeah if it doesn't work it's it should
be top priority like if you have a
master slave set up and you wanted to on
MySQL you wanted to failover
automatically or you have a network
setup that needs to failover
automatically fix it right away
I mean that includes network failover
anything really like even a system
restore from backup it should be fixed
it should be top priority in any case